[Applause]
[Music]
hi
followers of visualpolitik my name is
gabriel kluckler
i'm a principal advisor in the
communications department of the
european central bank
hi my name is imran islam and i am a
cyber specialist
at the european central bank working in
market infrastructure and payments
my name is diek bulman i'm the
innovation team lead
in the market infrastructure and
payments department here at the european
central bank
[Applause]
with an initial exchange rate of 1.178
the euro was born on the 1st of january
1999.
it began to operate as an electronic
currency used in financial markets and
for cashless payments
however it wouldn't be until three years
later that is at the beginning of 2002
when the euro coins and
notes that we know today began to
circulate it all started a decade
earlier on january the 1st 1991 when 11
member countries of the european union
decided to integrate their local
currencies currencies such as the mark
frank lira or peseta under the
supervising umbrella of the european
central bank
and with that the euro era began
[Music]
espana
and it did so in style expectations
were absolutely huge perhaps no one
showed more confidence in this new
currency than the european commissioner
for monetary affairs
eve thibaut
the euro will suppress monetary
instability reduce the cost of companies
and guarantee low and stable interest
rates today nobody would imagine the
united states with 50 currencies the
dollar has made this country strong
the euro will make europe's voice heard
louder all over the world which will
allow it to better defend its interests
which go far beyond purely monetary ones
iftabeau european commissioner for
monetary affairs
[Music]
since then 20 years have passed a time
in which the new european currency has
gone through both good
and bad times which means on many
occasions the euro has been
a big topic of public debate
because folks we can't deny the news is
notoriously pessimistic catastrophes and
bad news draw more attention than
positive events
it's easy to believe that the latest
news supersedes any
slow and steady trend so in recent years
we've all been hearing
all kinds of theories about what the
euro has meant and forecasts about the
currency's future
surely you must have heard at some point
that the euro is doomed or that its
arrival led to winning and losing
countries within the eurozone but
well what's the truth what assessment
can we make of the 20 years that the
euro has been part
of most europeans daily lives and what
challenges
does it face
[Music]
well thanks to the support and
sponsorship of the european central bank
some of visualpolitik's team members we
traveled to frankfurt to
seek answers to those questions and
celebrate the 20th anniversary of the
european currency
[Music]
the european central bank is therefore
to help europeans
to be able to spend their money to
invest it
to borrow money with confidence we want
to make sure that money is
stable and that the banks and people the
money in are safe
[Music]
in this video we're going to try and
find out what the euro has meant and
what challenges
it faces so let's get into it
[Music]
unity is strength
i think the first question we need to
ask ourselves is quite clear how
and why did the euro emerge to answer
this question we need to go back to the
1980s a decade that wasn't particularly
good for europeans
at that time europe's economy was not
having a great time these were years
of stagnation and bad statistics for
example unemployment in the european
communities countries had practically
doubled going from 5.8
in to over 11 percent just five years
later
potential growth had decreased by three
points public deficits had begun to
emerge with levels above three percent
and to make matters worse the united
states one of the main destinations for
european exports was heavily increasing
its restrictions
on imports
well it was in this context that the
idea of building
a true common market emerged something
that would allow
european nations to boost trade and
subsequently strengthen
their economic growth the idea was to
create a market without barriers without
customs without tariffs without
restrictions for all goods to do so all
administrative obstacles would have to
be eliminated and the disparity between
rules and regulations
had to be ended if a product could be
sold in one country of the union it
could be sold
in any of them but not only that a
genuine common market had to work with
the same currency and with the same
monetary policy among other things this
would prevent countries competing with
each other by devaluing their respective
currencies
over and over again and that was quite
common in those times for example
between 1979 and 1992
alone italy devalued the lira seven
times yep that's right in 13 years they
had
seven devaluations
the idea was to create a single market
that would be as large
and as competitive as that of the united
states and to help rebuild
uh europe after the war now that went
well
things moved moved moved ahead but then
you realize
that each country having their own
currency is in fact a barrier to that
deeper integration
and europeans have been trying all sorts
of things to make sure
that competitive devaluations where one
country makes a big effort
to be competitive and so on gets undone
by evaluate devaluation of another
country and they've tried it through
various means
the uh european monetary system and so
on so forth
and in comes the idea of monetary union
again a gigantic
uh revolutionary idea thinking
completely outside the box
europeans said let's not fix exchange
rates
let's do away with exchange rate
altogether let's have one currency
a single currency
and what's more setting a common
currency would make trade between
european countries a lot easier
companies that no longer have to look at
exchange rates monetary policy decisions
from different governments or currency
risk hedges
among many other issues
[Music]
and you know what the creation of the
single market has been a clear
example of success it simply has
fulfilled its objective
intra-community exports have moved from
representing 13
of the european union's gdp in 1992 to
more than
20 today and the volume of
intra-community investments
has also skyrocketed
and in all honesty throughout this
entire process the euro
has played a key role the euro has now
been with us for 20 years
so what conclusions can we draw well has
it been good or bad
for europeans so let's take a look
[Music]
the time of the euro
folks europe has changed a lot in the
last 20 years in some cases for good
and in some cases for well not so good
but at this point let me ask you a
question
what do you think do you think the euro
has been good or bad for europe well
folks
with data in hand i think we can say
that in general its influence has been
positive we've talked about this a lot
here previously on visualpolitik but the
question it really has to be how
positive
has the change been
[Music]
money has always been a language ex to
to express value how much do you value
something
these days there's 340 million europeans
who only have one common language to
express how much is
a thing is worth to them and that's an
euro
even if we speak different languages our
language of expressing value
is the euro and that kind of brings us
together
and uh and that's a true a true benefit
a further benefit would be if you go
abroad
if you go i don't know to bangkok and
you give your rickshaw driver
a dollar note they will say yes that's
an interesting thing i will take that
these days if you go to bangkok or you
go to
to istanbul and you hand out a five euro
note people will gladly take that
that's the benefit of having
international currency that wouldn't
have happened with the peseta
i would assume in the old days we have
created a currency
that is stable where inflation is low
and where there's
a an environment of of stability and
certainty
that's a great benefit many many people
across many parts of europe had not
experienced that for decades
now they have it and has become the most
normal thing of the world
well let's put some numbers on the table
shall we
nowadays more than 340 million people
use the euro and it has replaced
national currencies in 19 of the 28
states that make up the european union
[Music]
since its inception the eurozone's gdp
per capita has increased by 52
going from about 21 000 euros to more
than 32 000 euros today and the work
participation rate is higher in the
eurozone than it is
in the united states in spite of that
inflation has reached an average of 1.7
percent a rate lower than ones recorded
in the 70s 80s or even the 90s
in fact the euro zone's inflation level
in these 20 years has been lower than
that of the federal republic of germany
over the same period of time
[Music]
well each country in a sense that does
not have the euro have
to decide for itself when is the right
moment
to join the euro those who are members
of the european union
have signed the treaty that eventually
commits them to also join the eurozone
when the conditions are right
and countries have to decide for
themselves when the conditions
are right when they think that now the
economy is fit enough
it's developed enough it has the right
institutions it functions well enough
this might explain the euro's huge
popularity actually only 20
of europeans are against the idea
according to the latest surveys three
out of every four european citizens have
a good opinion of the currency and think
that it's generally been positive and
let's not kid ourselves
it isn't strange for them to think so
i'm sure that if you were offered to
have your savings in euros or pesetas or
in some currency today that resembles
the peseta you probably wouldn't think
twice about it but hold on a second
because not everything has been
sunshines and rainbows in the last 20
years the euro has also faced
some very hard times
[Music]
the stressful years
between 2008 and 2012 things became very
difficult the global financial crisis
caused a list of problems in most
western countries and true nightmares in
some of the countries using the euro
such as greece
italy ireland spain or portugal clearly
that's when the idea of two
europes emerged
on the one hand where the central and
northern european countries countries
that
generally have high productivity indexes
competitive industries and relatively
responsible leaderships
and on the other hand we had countries
that historically attempted to compete
by devaluing their currencies
when this option was ruled out due to
the euro they had boosted domestic
demand through strong
imbalances in their payments balance in
other words they financed most of their
spending via consumption and
investments with funding from abroad
basically from northern
and central european countries
and this money was largely concentrated
in the real estate sector we're talking
about countries where the local
governments didn't implement any
structural reforms that would allow them
to be more competitive and whose banks
were overloaded with
loans linked to the real estate bubble
loans that of course lost a lot of their
value when this bubble burst which
obviously put the banks against the wall
[Music]
greece portugal spain and ireland
although ireland's case is a bit
different
required some form of financial
assistance at that time the distrust and
problems were so
huge that as you might have heard there
was speculation about the possible
rupture of the euro among other things
because many european states had to pay
such high premiums that their situation
was made completely unstable they simply
could not
finance themselves
in the end the member countries of the
eurozone decided to do everything they
could to avoid that scenario and it was
then that the european
central bank president mario draghi
pronounced these famous words on july
the 26th
2012. within our mandate the ecb
is ready to do whatever it takes to
preserve the euro and believe me
it will be enough mario draghi
this meant that the european central
bank would adopt extraordinary measures
to stabilize the euro it started to give
longer-term loans to banks to buy a
range of assets from banks
including government bonds and corporate
bonds so that businesses and people were
able to borrow
more and spend less to repay their debts
this has led to more economic growth
and inflation
i think the hardest time for the euro
was
when the crisis which was initially an
economic crisis a financial crisis the
banking crisis
turned into a crisis of trust at crisis
of confidence
when people lost confidence that
the euro as a project is a good thing
the euro will survive
that countries will do the right thing
to stay in the euro when people started
doubting that
that was i think the hardest moment
because to lose trust
and confidence is very quick to rebuild
it is very hard
if you go out and ask people in the
financial markets there were certainly
some people
who thought the euro would disappear
some might even be
looking forward to it because an
opportunity to make money
um often forgetting what catastrophic
responses
uh consequently would have had um
and maybe also if you ask people in the
streets feeding
being fed some of the of the media
commentary
had had had doubts about it if you read
the headline
the euros got 10 days to live
that you had in some some papers then
it is natural that people start to
wonder whether this is really solid
but what's most important in this is
that exposed
people have seen that yes if push comes
to shove
the europeans get their act together and
they will do what is necessary
or in the words of our president
whatever it takes to make sure
the euro will survive
i think there is an understanding that
we haven't
done all the jobs that we need to do
that we've done
good progress we made good progress but
there's more to do
the completion of banking union is one
thing the uh
the working on what we call a capital
markets union
is a very important point and there are
other elements about economic union and
all the way to
a deeper political union and say how do
we make sure
that the benefits of the single currency
which are there are shared equally and
that everyone
even those in countries that have
suffered from the crisis fear yes
this is a good project that also helps
me personally
[Music]
but folks at this point the question we
need to ask ourselves is this
is the eurozone really prepared to face
a new crisis what could happen in the
future if one of the euro member
countries has some problems well folks
over the last few years a lot of
different mechanisms have emerged and
have been implemented in order to
strengthen
the euro's resistance and i can tell you
right now that a lot of these things are
a bit of a mouthful for example we have
the
mip macroeconomic imbalance procedure
and the esrb
the european systemic risk board this is
also the esm the european stability
mechanism which has been
established among other things to
provide financial assistance to the
member countries if they need it it can
mobilize up to 500 billion euros and
has already been used to assist greece
and spain with their famous bank
bailouts
[Music]
i think we've made good progress in
completing banking union that has three
pillars
a single way of supervising banks a
single mechanism to make sure if banks
are in trouble and they're failing that
we can resolve them
what we're missing is the third pillar
is a common deposit insurance can seem
so that
wherever you put your money into the
bank
your deposit is safe throughout
regardless which country and which bank
that is to make sure kind of a euro is a
euro
wherever it is in which bank account it
is across the entire eurozone
[Music]
and that's not all existing institutions
such as the stability and growth pact
have also been reinforced it requires a
three percent limit on public deficit
and 60
on public debt from member countries
and also by virtue of the fiscal
stability treaty almost all european
union countries have included the
requirement of having
balanced budgets throughout the cycle in
their national legislation
let's hope they respect their
legislation the european central bank
has also increased its capabilities to
deal with emergencies
in short as you see a lot of changes
have taken place with the aim of
reducing the risk of crisis and if
necessary limiting its impact
the question is are these measures
enough or should we continue to move
forward for example with a fiscal union
and right there folks
is one of the great debates that exists
right now in europe
but hold on a second because crises
aren't the only challenges facing the
european central bank and the euro
the arrival of cryptocurrency and
blockchain have also raised questions
these are will new financial
technologies be able to change the way
that money works do they pose
a threat to traditional currencies
blockchain is a is a what we see as an
infrastructure
so you can see it as a road and and
bitcoin or other crypto assets these are
for us
the cars on the on the infrastructure in
a very simplified way
we think that the technology is
promising and
it's not yet maybe ready for prime time
for us but it's not a threat
it's more an opportunity so that's it on
the infrastructure side
but then you have the the assets the
bitcoin and so i think a lot has been
said by by many central bankers around
the world
uh of course crypto assets high
volatility
and they are not currency they are not
money and
our president also recently said the
euro today is a euro tomorrow
and with bitcoin maybe it's different
because there's no identifiable issuer
there's no one
responsible behind the currency making
sure that it's
that it's stable
[Music]
[Applause]
and well this brings us to another very
important question and that's what about
cyber security
especially in a world where the storage
of financial records is digital and the
only way to access the information or
perform a transaction
requires a digital device
it's a new form of warfare in many ways
so you also have threat actors you know
nation states activist groups you know
script kiddies
all of them that have become more
professional
and more persistent and better resourced
to be able to target the financial
system
why does this matter to the european
central bank well
we ultimately have a mandate which is
around financial stability
ensuring confidence in the euro itself
so if there is a disruption to the
financial system
if the integrity of data is compromised
in the financial system then it has a
possible contagion effect
right across the financial system
[Music]
folks europe is facing a lot of
challenges some of which we've already
talked about on this channel
challenges such as aging populations
growing international competition
imbalances
in the public accounts of many of the
member countries or even defining
exactly what european model we all want
to follow
the european parliament elections will
take place from may the 23rd to may the
26th that depends on the country in
which you
live in one way or another this is the
moment in which all european citizens
will have the chance to speak
out and decide what future we want for
europe and what kind of union
we want so well now you know in the
meantime if you found this video
interesting please
do give us a like below and once again
many thanks to the european central bank
for
helping make this video possible then as
always
thank you for watching and if you want
to learn more about politics and hear
even more of my lovely voice you can
join us at reconsider media we have a
podcast at reconsider
media.com podcast see you there